the script came with quite a funny um
approach which was like Wes says Dear ra
here's a script I'd like you to read
please let me know what part you would
like to
play so I read the script and there's
this great part called good staff and I
think am I allowed to say that I'd like
to play G Stu one of the first things
that I asked was where do we where does
what's the Nuance what's the tone of
gustaff cuz clearly it it could lend
itself to sort of high definition
flamboyancy slash
cery uh and what was it you know where
where did it lie and one of one of our
first earliest meetings was to read
through it it seemed to me that you
didn't want it to become overly affected
it needed to be rooted in sort of more
you